in the last few videos we talked about
we talked about the greco-persian
wars or we could say the persian
invasion of greece and in the first wave
the first persian invasion the athenians
were able to stop them at marathon and
then in the second persian invasion led
by xerxes they were able to route the
persian navy at salamis and eventually
get rid of the persians all together at
platia in in
479 bce so at that point the greeks
especially the city-states the powerful
city-states of sparta and athens they're
fighting on the same side but as we'll
see in this video this all starts to
break down and they will eventually be
at war with each other in a very ugly
war you know a lot of times when we
think about these things thousands of
years later it might seem somewhat
romantic the stuff of stories and
adventures
but these things are ugly people are
getting killed people are getting
tortured civilians are dying whole
cities are being destroyed
now whenever we talk about history it's
very important to think about where your
story is coming from and you should
always have a nice
dose of doubt on what were the
motivations of the person who wrote it
or how much can they really know about
things and when we talked about the
persian invasions of greece or the
greco-persian wars that was coming us
from that was coming to us from someone
who is often known as the father of
history i guess that's a very uh
greco-centric perspective but that is
herodotus
and now we're going to start getting our
accounts from someone who wrote the
famous history of the peloponnesian war
and that is thucydides and they're so
closely linked especially because
they're giving history of essentially
this fifth century bce that this is
actually a double bust of the two
herodotus and thucydides so once again a
lot of the story that i'm about to tell
is coming via through cities
so as soon as the the persians are there
they've
they've been defeated they leave you
might remember that the athenians had to
escape to salamis that's where you also
had the naval route of the persian navy
and so the athenians decide hey let's
let's move back to athens
and in deciding to move back to athens
right over there they say okay well we
want to build a wall around athens in
case anyone else wants to invade us
and you might say okay maybe they're
somewhat concerned about the persians
but you could also argue that they're
somewhat concerned about the spartans
who are famous for having this very
powerful
this very powerful army and so they
start the construction on what's often
called the long wall and it's a way for
them to have access to the sea and to
protect their city in the event of a
siege
now if you take the other side if you
think about what's going on in the minds
of the spartans they are thinking okay
you know for a long time we were really
the dominant military power but what
we've just seen with the with the
greco-persian wars is this athenian navy
is actually quite strong and in some
ways you in fact in a lot of ways you
can argue that they're the ones that
were able to beat off the persians at
salamis that the navy was
essential there
so sparta is feeling a little bit
threatened and in particular they don't
like the idea of this wall because here
you have the city-state athens with this
very strong navy now they're building a
wall sparta says hey if they have a wall
it's going to be very hard for us if if
they don't do what you know if they
think if if they start exerting too much
influence it's going to be hard for us
to to take down athens they instead
suggest hey athens why don't you build a
wall why don't you build a wall at the
ithmus
of corinth right over here you might
notice the geography of greece you have
this little i guess you could call it
this little strip of land that contain
that connects the mainland you could say
to
the to this this peninsula this very
large peninsula which is called the
peloponnese
which is where sparta is and you can
imagine that this is a very strategic
location anyone who wants to conquer the
peloponnese by land is going to have to
go is going to have to go through there
but the athenians are of course no we
care about protecting ourselves
and so they start to build this wall to
protect themselves which the spartans
already are not so happy about
now the other thing that the athenians
do they continue to build up their naval
power they see hey this is a very useful
thing
they start connecting with a bunch of
allies around the aegean some on island
someone on in on the the coast of
anatolia over here
and they meet at on the island of delos
which you can't see here it's a very
small
island and they all agree to contribute
their shared navies and to contribute uh
money
in order to continue to fight off the
persians wherever they are you know
these persians did this injustice to us
now let's go on the offensive and they
form what is called the delian league
now once again sparta is not so happy
about this because more and more it
becomes clear that the stallion league
athens isn't just a participant in the
delian league athens is starting to run
the delian league and when people try to
drop out of the delhi league over time
athens starts to exert itself so the
delian league is really stirring more
and more and more into an athenian
empire so once again athens proved
itself its navy proved itself to be very
powerful in this war sparta is getting
insecure athens doesn't listen to sparta
about this wall and decides to start
building it
as part of feeling even more insecure
athens is starting to create this delia
league which is really an athenian
empire even more insecure
and it kind of gets a little bit more
intense
in 464.
so there are some accounts that sparta
around this time was already planning to
invade athens to say hey these these
folks are getting too powerful let's
just put them in their place but at
around that time in 464 you have a major
earthquake you have a major earthquake
in sparta and so it demolishes large
parts of the city and when that
earthquake happens
the spartan
helots who i guess the best way you can
view them they are slaves and i
encourage you to read more about them
they were treated uh horribly and in in
sparta the the accounts are that there
were seven of these hell outs of these
slaves for every spartan and so the
helots start a revolt and sparta goes to
the other city-states of greece and says
help us
put down this revolt that happened right
after our earthquake and so athens
agrees they send 4 000 citizen soldiers
to sparta the citizen soldiers of famous
hoplites to help put down the revolt but
once again sparta is feeling insecure
they say
hey you know what why did they send
these soldiers maybe they they say they
want to put down this rebellion but uh
we sparta we're kind of in a fairly
vulnerable state right here what if what
if the athenians took the side of the
helots well then they might be able to
take over sparta so they send
the athenian hoplites back they said you
know we we don't need your help and so
you can imagine the athenians now are
starting to take significant offense to
how the spartans are treating them and
then you fast forward a little bit more
to 459 bce
and you have two allies of sparta megara
and corinth and they're right in this
very strategic location that little land
that land connection that land bridge
between the mainland and the peloponnese
and there is a dispute between these two
allies of sparta between corinth and
megara
and athens decides to intervene and form
an alliance with megara well you can
imagine you know this insecurity has
been building up in sparta for at this
point uh over over a decade and so it
all comes to head and they start having
skirmishes and they start essentially
going to war with each other they have
these sporadic skirmishes over the next
15 years and this period right over here
from roughly 4
460 or 459 for the next 15 years this is
often referred to as the first
peloponnesian war because once again you
have sparta and its allies starting to
get into all of these skirmishes with
athens and its allies but this isn't the
peloponnesian war the peloponnesian war
is going to come a little bit about 15
years later the first peloponnesian war
that we're just talking about that
eventually ends what's called a 30 years
peace this peace treaty which only lasts
for 15 years but at the the whole time
the athenians their navy is growing more
powerful they keep getting in each
other's way and annoying each other and
so the peloponnesian war which we'll
talk about in more detail will occur
at the end of the 5th century bce and it
will conclude with sparta being victory
victorious but in in the process
most of greece is uh is significantly a
hurt and all of the city-states or the
significant city-states of greece are
significantly weakened and so that sets
things up for the 4th century
bce where it leads it leaves the
city-states of greece vulnerable to
attack from the north in particular
macedonia macedonia and we'll see that
actually several videos in the future